so as we come back to our regular
schedule I want to pick up now with our
versiv series then I was going to the
comments on my previous video and what I
had noticed is that a lot of you guys
were asking the question who would win
in a battle between world breaker Hulk
and doomsday and so that's what we're
gonna talk about here but first the
first thing I want to do anyway is run
over what the powers of these guys are
and what they're capable of so in order
to remove the Hulk from the Marvel
landscape for the Civil War then writer
Greg Pak wrote a story called Planet
Hulk which saw the Illuminati launch
Hulk into space because they felt he
become too much of a threat to continue
living on earth now their intention was
to send the Hulk to a planet where he
could live out his life in peace without
hurting anyone but a shuttle entered a
wormhole and he unexpectedly ended up on
the planet called Sekar which was led by
an evil dictator known as the Red King
now eventually the hope defeats the Red
King marries a woman named Kiera and
finds a life of happiness on Sekar
however everything turned sour when the
shuttle which brought it back to the car
explodes destroying the city and killing
his wife and unborn child in the process
and so as a result the Hulk eventually
loses it blames the Illuminati since
they designed the shuttle and returns to
Earth to exact his revenge
now following these events Greg pack
launched the next chapter of Hulk story
called world war hulk during which time
were introduced to the concept of the
world breaker hulk which shows us what
happens when hulk returns to earth and
declares war on his betrayers now what
we see here is that Hulk is at a level
of power that's never been seen prior to
this point like all incarnations of the
Hulk war breaker Hulk has super strength
and his level of strength varies
directly on his level of anger with no
upper limit this principle explains the
immense level of strength of the world
breaker Hulk and what he exhibits and
that because he lives in constant anger
due to the destruction of sakaar and the
end of his new life the baseline
strength in his hope form is already
extremely high and increases even
further as he engages in battle and so
during the world breaker hulk event and
its tie-ins we saw several feats of
strength from the hulk they give us an
idea of just how strong he is in his
world breaker hulk formed for instance
he was able to jump high enough to enter
the Earth's orbit and far enough to
travel across continents now in addition
to the limitless super strength and
durability as well as extremely
efficient healing
actors rule-breaker Hulk is able to emit
gamma radiation from his body with
devastating effects before example with
nearly one footstep the wallbreaker Hulk
destroyed almost the entire eastern
seaboard of the United States we also
saw battle with the Red Hulk where the
Incredible Hulk performs a thunderclap
that releases enough radiation to
completely incapacitate the Red Hulk and
so basically what we have in world
breaker Hulk is the strongest most
durable Hulk that we've ever seen due to
him being the angriest he's ever been
and added an ability to project
extremely powerful blasts of gamma
radiation
now all these powers combine to make war
breaker for quite possibly the strongest
earthbound and even Universal entity in
the history of Marvel Comics save for
those who can warp reality and the
reason we can say this is that we see
him go up against and defeat several of
the strongest heroes in the Marvel
Universe performing impressive feats of
strength along the way for example we
saw Hulk travel to the moon to get front
Black Bolt and withstand the sonic blast
generated by his voice before defeating
him in battle and continuing on to earth
woody arise Hulk travels to the Xavier
school to confront another member of the
Illuminati Charles Xavier and during a
battle with the x-men hoax able to break
Colossus his arms while he's in his
organic steel form and is able to
withstand an attack from the juggernaut
before eventually throwing him through a
brick wall now following this the Hulk
battles dr. strange who's been possessed
by a super powerful demon named Tom and
defeats him a feat that should have been
impossible since it took the combined
strength of both Dormammu and the cosmic
entity eternity to imprisons on the most
impressive feat that we saw achieved by
world war hulk however comes during his
battle with the century who is believed
to be one of if not the strongest hero
in the Marvel Universe
while Hulk and sentry initially battled
to a standstill the century finally
expends all his energy in an attempt to
defeat the Hulk but the Hulk withstands
this attack and the century and Hulk
both turned back into their human forms
now in 2011 four years after the world
war hulk event we saw the world record
form of folk emerge again in an event
called heart of the monster in the story
The Hulk once again became angry enough
to enter his world breaker form after
the villain Armageddon poison Jen
Walters and Rick Jones this time is what
Wicker Hulk he's able to defeat powering
up versions of Fin Fang Foom by beast
Wendigo red she-hulk and army of
mindless ones and
getting himself as well as destroy an
entire planet within the Dark Dimension
and so having said that what I want to
do here is I want a transition to
doomsday because he is not a pushover
Doomsday's power set is extremely
similar to the Hawks for example like
the Hulk
doomsday possesses super-strength
doomsday strength level has varied
throughout history but he has
effectively battled and defeated both
Superman and Darkseid even killing
Superman on one occasion and the
now-famous death of Superman's story arc
and breaking his arm and another so we
can assume that his strength level is
among the upper echelon of characters in
the DC Universe and he's also been known
to leap miles at a time again much like
the Hulk but in addition to strength
doomsday possesses superhuman stamina as
he was able to battle Superman for an
entire day but he also has an armored
hide and almost instantaneous healing
that makes him extremely resistant to
physical damage however what really sets
doomsday apart is his ability to
involuntarily return from the dead
anytime that he's killed furthermore
each time he dies doomsday comes back
immune to whatever it was that killed
him the previous time and so because of
this he's also shown the ability to
quickly evolve his DNA to exploit his
opponent's weaknesses including one
instance when he breathes fire while he
was fighting Martian Manhunter and so
the question becomes this between these
two characters and with their feats and
powers outlined who wins well the reason
this is such an interesting battle with
so many people is that it hits two
characters with very similar powers and
immense strength against one another
that being said I think that at first
this battle will be a virtual stalemate
as each combatant raids blows in an
outright brawl I don't really see any
real weaknesses that either one could
exploit in order to gain any sort of
advantage on the other as each character
is basically built to be an impenetrable
tank that absorbs damage and keeps
fighting through it on the other hand
the respective strengths durability and
healing factors of each of these
characters would also ensure that the
battle they have would go on for an
extended period of time which I think
favors the whole as he'll continue to
grow angrier the longer he battles on
with his strengths continuing to
increase this also presents an
interesting contrast with the battle
doomsday had with Superman which I know
will be a sticking point for many when
gauging Doomsday's abilities since
Superman does
suffer fatigue during the prolonged
battle causing him to weaken however
this will not be a problem for the Hulk
and so simply become more powerful the
longer the fight goes on the issue with
us however is that we're not really
giving an answer which is essentially
the point of these videos so we'll put
that entire concept aside and we'll
basically just pick a winner here with
that said I think that if these two are
simply battling to the death will
breaker Hulk will probably win I say
that because from everything that we've
seen the Hulk is just as powerful
resilient and durable as doomsday being
as there's no upper limit to his
strength we have however seen doomsday
defeated in DC Comics on more than one
occasion while we've never seen the hope
defeated while in his world breaker form
now things change significantly though
if doomsday once again engages the Hulk
after he returns to life since he will
be immune to what caused his death it
will become harder if not impossible for
the Hulk to actually kill him but I'm
not sure that doomsday would ever
actually reach a level sufficient enough
to kill world breaker Hulk since again
home continues to get stronger the
angrier he gets and so what this does is
effectively just put us back to a
stalemate scenario so again this is
really just kind of a hard situation to
figure out here because we've got a guy
whose anger could stretch on forever but
we've also got a guy who can keep coming
back from the dead so I'm curious like
in my opinion I think well wrecker Hulk
would probably win the issue with this
is that it takes time for Hulk to get up
to that form so supposed to comment down
below I'm kind of curious who do you
guys think would win in a battle between
world breaker Hulk and doomsday I know
this is probably gonna create a lot of
argument it's gonna create a lot of
debate I know like the hardcore DC fans
and the hardcore Marvel fans are gonna
take their sides and they're gonna
refuse to give ground so be as civil as
you can in the comments section but I'm
really curious to read the answers that
you guys are gonna give and yeah if you
guys enjoyed this video if you guys want
to see more like it make sure you hit
the like button make sure you get the
sub button to become part of the rock
court and I will catch you guys later
peace